acom alter was geht was geht das betteln
mein zimmer und es finde ich echt nicht
fair
ich hatte eine große klasse ich meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen zur
weiteren folge
germain am mittwoch tot
nein ich will sie nicht der bitte nicht
sterben duca bitte nicht der mitte nicht
haben eineinhalb eineinhalb 1 alter du
bist ich sterbe dem stift jetzt also
wieder bei der man fange ich jetzt über
die lava altern jetzt müssen wir beide
noch mal machen weil ich schaffe das er
beim ersten mal guck ich auch als ich
vor ort nicht porto schade vom alter bin
immer wieder angesprochen
ich hoffe dass gerade bei jedem
durchlauf ich habe auch geschafft
nach tod weil diese lover springe ich
glaube die kakteen sind da wirklich nur
halb so schwer man im moment bettwäsche
im bett mit hey lasst man die angel
draufkommen bitte einwender beihilfe ich
glaube beide alte jurist ich habe meine
blätter metternich auf der gerne
eingeladen aber als gleichheit mann band
ist tot
ich habe mein wetter bei jungen ich hab
ich also angela eiter berichtet hin
boa wo du stehst weiß was jetzt mach ich
bin jetzt richtig chicchi an ihr geht
gar nicht ich wollte mir mein bett hier
hinsetzen joachim bönsch chances are sie
das war also die alter du bist ein pizza
alter ich bin besser werden in mein bett
liegt da gleich will ich muss mich die
ganze zeit porten glaube ich ja ich
brauche mein wert auf ihr mann
ich brenne schon wieder du bist noch mal
ein bett hilfe und jetzt kann jetzt ins
pony mal bei meinem bett
zachmann von crafter diese sprünge die
regen mich auch für beide verlagern
jetzt mal unser bett fällig ich hab
meins abgebaut also darüber nützen nicht
sterben als erstes ja okay ich mein
erstes ich bin hier vertrauenspersonen
für ein schlag
du hast was gemacht habe ich nicht du
hast was gemacht habe überlebt dass ich
überlebt habe nichts gemacht wird im
safe überlebe ich das
nele fragt daniela was haltet ihr davon
dass grundschüler schon ein smartphone
haben boxclubs thema koma
das ist aber schon gras aber als ich bin
drüben ich auch ich habe gerade den
sprung geschafft du brauchst mehr bahnen
bett vorlieben schlafen schlafen
schlafen schlafen brands
wenn du das nicht erlebt ich will diesen
stoff mir sorgen arsch wenn du das nicht
überlebt hätte aber richtig anwendet
also ich halte davon gar nichts ich
finde das so packe die komplette
kommunikation geht schief wenn die zum
smartphone
also gilt natürlich kommunizieren
miteinander und so was alles aber sie
sind dann einfach alle am arsch
ich verstehe das gar nicht warum die
eltern das auch machen natürlich man
will die kinder immer erreichen und so
aber warum spö nicht ändert sich von
meinem bett weil zu schlecht da man
immer bei jedem sprung wo es
kontrollieren
warum denn vielleicht mal einmal mein
bett schlafen muss ich muss mich immer
teleportieren schon wieder ich schaffe
das jetzt einfach sage ich mir
bestehende stehen nein
hp com wir schlafen erwarte schafft das
aber gerade was ist das für ein sprung
der bitte die kammer nicht schaffen doch
die kann man schaffen
du sagst du ja kommen wir schlafen mal
eben geht einfach nicht schlafen da
geschafft da aber verbrannt ok alter ich
wollte schlafen gehen
warte jetzt mal jetzt du wirst auch mal
warten ich mich zu dir herr mache ich
gleich man warum lag dass hier gerade
schon wieder ich kann mich gar nicht
eine folge besteht nur aus porten weil
ich nicht zu denen kann weil er komme
immer so egozentrisch ist und die ja
befeuert unbedingt willen hättest du
bereinigt in die damen geschubst akon
kraft setzt du mich nicht in die lava
geschubst aber ich schon viel weiter
aha ach so jetzt macht mal hinter da ja
ich bin tot
gut ich konnte mich zu dir ich bin in
der lage schpakow ok ab ins bett
es ist tot ich betreibe kann ich denn
gar nichts ich im bett kommt auch ein es
monster in der nähe
du bist ja auch mal im ernst ich kann
nicht schlafen also dass kaka bei dir
kann ich schlafe aber bei mir geht aber
sollte auch reichen
der tschechische wieder was ist wenn ich
jetzt tot bin ja wohl komme zeigt euch
mal wie das geht hier richtig denn oft
einfach rein
auch das ist so eine solche kag sprünge
hier bei new opel jetzt gerade läuft
also das halte ich hätte ihn auch
beinahe geschafft werde ich dann noch
ein wenig mehr leben gehabt also ich
denke ich werde mein kind auf jeden fall
kommt drauf an liefert die technik ist
wennigloh es kommt darauf an wie weit
die technik ist wenn meine kinder in dem
alter halt sind muss man gucken richtig
theoretisch auch hier sollen die kurve
springen es gibt ein bisschen
schwieriger glaube ich alter das kann
doch nicht sein das ist das hardcore
junge ich bin immer direkt tot
ok hab ich geschafft
ich wollte sagen ohne zu brennen aber
ich brenne
was machbar was soll hier du hast mich
auch geschlagen
ich hab dich jetzt darüber geschlafen
kollege bürgerlich gesinnte hier kommt
krise augen guten burger ich werde mir
mit bürgern aber vettel ab
das ist sehr schwer da wieder hat der
kollege hallo hallo das ist auch kacke
jetzt vorrechten thema avastin von
tokina mit smartphones ja finde ich
natürlich auch nicht gut weil das
natürlich schon in jungen jahren gerade
denke ich mal nicht gerade irgendwie das
eigenständige denken fördert daher viele
natürlich mit dem smartphone auch dann
zu google und so weiter gehen und -
natürlich wünsche und handlich waldwegen
in die bücherei und sich der mann buch
ausleihen weißt du beschreibt weil ich
bin irgendwie auch video hat schon sagt
dass da geht nicht nur die kommunikation
verloren sondern auch irgendwie keine
ahnung wieso ein stück kindheit weil es
mit den smartphones und computern und so
sollte man finde ich echt ernst mit man
halte ich hatte kein leben verloren
warum haustür ich darunter weil ich das
schaffe ich sagte ich hoffe dass jetzt
nicht gutes gefühl gerade gar nicht
schaffst using butters wort du schaffst
das
ohne spaß macht alex du schaffst
geschafft geschafft dass ich gut ich
gebe das bild was er hängt dafür dass so
hat die stays ja warum sind diesen
leiter sprünge monaten recht komisch was
kann ich
der ist sagt ich war immer seine
landschaft richtiger naturbo jetzt
universe bild reuters bilder streep hat
er uns beobachtete er die piper die sind
böse ich werde ihm die sz angestrebt von
so einem tipp lass mich auch mal rein
du hast kein sound anleihen muss wieder
zurück
da wollen wir den tim mal rein holen
oder was den pc kommen wir wohl mal den
film rein soll ich machen fragen seien
in klammern tim und dann nochmals in
wetzlar beike 4g sowie im rhein okay wir
holen die siebenmeter ein zuschauer
ja ich hab ihn warte ich habe so was
wollen wir denn frage wie fragen oder
willst du mein zimmer und das finde ich
echt nicht fair
ich habe eine grosse klasse wie alt bist
du dein tipp
das ist ein ganz normaler frage weil wir
gerade noch immer so was geredet haben
und die große ja das gibt's den 32 zoll
nein das ist jetzt wollte man kurz den
alle unten in den channel in lacken zwei
willst es war die schule nach dem
worüber wir lagern sollen
ich will scharf gerade den sprüchen
wirkung geholfen hier sein wird die die
migros selbst nicht die ganze anstupsen
sind die böse die krasseste beleidigung
wie du kennst du doch sagt auch bestimmt
nicht abhängen gegeben und weg ist er
weg gegangen
ja klar er ist in die andere youtuber
ich brauche ich kann ich in die andere
ich habe keine vision und im sonst so du
bist jetzt ein neu komme wie geht's dir
so wollte störungen schnellverbindung
grad abwandern
ganz ehrlich ist natürlich erwartet dass
mich rein
ach du du hast so nicht geschrieben ruf
mich mal da dachte ich so nie da muss
ich dir einfach
bekomme ich bin übrigens partner und
rederecht du hast heute rederecht hier
er will zwar kurz in die prämie bekommen
und damit vornehmlich einmal anschauen
also ich habe er natürlich schon an die
email direkt nach der aufnahme ich bin
doch mal konkret auf der karte und
sonniger den kennst du noch gar nicht
mehr kommen ich kenne ja ja ja niemand
kennt hallo wir kennen auch einfach alle
tim mein bruder werde ich sprechen die
häuser bruder 14
wie heißt er 18 oder heißt der 14 julian
jahre alt ist
nein ich dachte hat den sprung geschafft
aber nein jetzt noch was machst du heute
so hallo hallo komme ich an gar nicht
ich habe die ganze zeit was gesagt was
mir redet aber ich höre ich hab gar kein
reden gehört habe ich nicht gehört
mein bruder ich von meinem bruder sagen
komme dass mein bruder dich früher 1
gefeiert hat aber jetzt so ein cod
suchte ihr seid zu nehmen er sagt ich
komme das was ich schon immer mal fragen
und ich hab auch mal angeschrieben aber
das nie geantwortet richtiger schlingel
was du von cod hält also ich hab mir
direkt thema fragen hier thema heimat
immer geil was halte ich von cod finde
ich auf jeden fall ist also ich habe
auch mal eine zeit lang wirklich stark
gespielt hatte da auch wirklich immer
patron schlecht ich hatte echt gute
runde also ich hatte teilt place hat mir
richtig spaß gemacht aber jetzt
eigentlich mittlerweile so die letzten
call of duty teile die haben ja alle
nicht wirklich so stark gefallen ja
irgendwann habe ich mir dann gesagt die
han e call of duty momentan ist nicht so
mein spiel war waltraud schreiben all
der action vertreten den erwähnten
beiden kriegen konnte minecraft ist echt
zum spiel ganz ehrlich das macht mit
durchgehend spaß wirklich ich habe jetzt
rechtzeitig minecraft spiele immer spaß
an minecraft bei call of duty hat nicht
mal so hoch ist und tiefs meiste was ein
minecraft hatte ich halt immer bock auf
eine karte also fast ein paar ja
eigentlich immer der böse anja und und
was sagst du dazu
herr kong crafter herr ruhig sagt dazu
dass ich auch eine zeit lang richtig
richtig viel cod gespielt aber sachen
klaren und so telefon
er ruft die ganze zeit an
er ist also ich kann ihnen gerne
annehmen da kommt ja auch noch rein wenn
heute nicht herumkommt schon alle in
klammern also erst alle wir müssen jetzt
erstmal die dings beenden die folge dem
hass irgendwelche and worte die du noch
sagen möchte seine zuschauer ich hab's
gewusst was sie aufnimmt
dieser zeit schon gemacht den ich aber
der duft italia dieser das telefon
was ich hab gesagt halte er gar nichts
der kontrast doch ihr einkommen 88 okay
wenn jetzt die folge leute jetzt euch
gefallen an das wetter das bei mir ist
wieder einmal glaube ich noch wird immer
besser